(whooshing)
- This program is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to A Conversation With History.
I'm Harry Kreisler,
of The Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is senior
judge, J. Clifford Wallace,
of the United States Court of
Appeals for the 9th Circuit.
He is the recipient, in 2008,
of the University of California
Berkeley School of Law,
Judge D. Lowell and Barbara
Jensen Public Service Award.
Judge Wallace, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much.
- Where were you born and raised?
- San Diego, in both instances.
- And looking back, how
did your childhood shape
your thinking about the
world, do you think?
What did you learn?
- I learned how to survive, primarily.
I grew up in a poor area of San Diego.
My father was an immigrant, and
had a third grade education,
and suffered from alcoholism.
He had difficulty supporting us.
My mother was a high school
dropout, very fine person,
but she had her own series of challenges.
So I don't think there was
much that happened in my home,
nor particularly in school,
and that wasn't the
school's fault, either.
I was just in an area and ran with people
that didn't put much high
mark on going to school
or education or otherwise.
As a matter of fact, I went
all the way through high school
without ever reading a book.
I found you could always get a C or a D
just by reading the book
cover and saying something,
so I was not an achiever at all.
But someplace along the line,
I got the idea I wanted to be a lawyer,
and never having been a
lawyer, it's rather striking,
but all the time I wanted to be a lawyer,
but it never computed that
you have to do something
to do that, and three years
in the Navy helped me out.
I qualified to go to a school for a year
under the Secretary of
Navy's Annapolis program,
and getting ready to take the exam,
so while other people were brushing up,
I was learning for the first time.
At the end of that year, I'd
done all my high school work
that I didn't do earlier,
and although I'd received an appointment
to go to the Naval Academy,
I decided against it,
because I decided that it was better off
if I went, continued my
process of going towards law,
and I did.
I came back and I went to
San Diego State University,
and ended up at Berkeley.
- In the law program.
So it's a fascinating
story, and I'm curious,
are there any influences
that shaped your character
that you can look back now,
see, I mean, clearly,
from what you just said,
you had intelligence going for you.
What else?
- Well, I wasn't aware of that.
I think I came to grips,
I came to grips with,
that I'm an individual,
that I have a purpose,
I have responsibility,
and that there's a certain
vision of life that I got,
and it was primarily finding a religion
with which I was compatible,
and got me to start
thinking in those lens,
so I give a lot of credit
to that, in shaping my view,
and in shaping my service,
the idea of being of
service to other people
came a lot out of that experience.
- Mm-hmm.
I think our audience would
be interested to know
what do you think are the
skills required to be a lawyer?
- Well, essentially,
you have to really care
about what you're doing
and not just how much money
you're taking to the bank.
It's a service organization.
We're doing something
for people they can't do.
It's hard work.
You have to be willing to put in the time,
whether you get paid for it or not.
There has to be a
feeling of accomplishment
of being of help to people,
and then secondarily is,
of course, taking care of your family,
and that's helpful, that's important, too.
It's problem solving,
and to the extent people
can learn how to solve
problems, it's helpful.
For example, they did a study
on what undergraduate courses
help the most to be a lawyer,
and I always thought it
was economics and poli sci,
and so I went through that,
but it turns out to be math.
So I think those skills are necessary,
but a person has to be
dedicated to a goal.
I think that helps a lot in
making success of the law,
and making it fulfilling for your life.
- Mm-hmm.
Now what about history and a
sense of the broader society?
I mean, for students, would
the taking of history,
to understand, for example,
the history of the Constitution,
of the nature of our
political system, and so on?
- Oh, I think that's a fair statement,
that looking at the
Constitution and the framers,
and understanding better what
they were trying to accomplish
gives you a better feeling,
a setting of what the law's all about,
and certainly, later on,
as your view broadens,
there's a lot of catch up that takes place
of things that you didn't study,
because you didn't think
they were that important,
and now they've become rather critical
in what you're trying to accomplish.
- Mm-hmm.
And you mentioned that your
religion was important to you.
Is that the source of
notions of equity and justice
or is it philosophy that
you have to turn to,
as you're weighing the pros
and cons of the arguments
in a particular case?
- Well, it'll impact
on all of those things,
but for my purpose, it was
just becoming sensitive
that I'm supposed to be doing something,
that I should be doing
something with my life,
that I can be of help,
that I can be creative,
that I can show some leadership,
and that I would be
disappointed in me after that
if I didn't do the work
necessary to accomplish that.
- But what about, as you
look at a particular case,
does your religion help you
find that notion of justice
and equity as you weigh
both sides of the argument,
or is it really just the
logic and the precedents
that you have before you,
and the particular facts of the case?
- I'm sure that it has
some indirect values,
but one of the things that you learn to do
is you must be guided by the law,
and it's the Constitution,
the statutes of the Congress
that we must apply,
not shaping them to our
view of what society
or whatever should be.
So in that regard, one has to be careful.
Someone asked me one time,
if you had to decide a case,
and it was against the
tenets of your church,
but consistent with the Constitution,
what would you do?
Well, that was an easy answer for me.
You'd follow the Constitution.
That's where I've taken my oath.
If I can't do that, I should step down.
So it has an indirect influence on you
to the extent it teaches
that we should be looking
outside ourselves,
to be of help, things like that.
But our main goal is to
apply the Constitution
and the statutes, and we can't allow
anything outside of that, no
matter how virtuous they are
to be an influence.
That's what people expect of
us, or should expect of us.
- I guess as a judge and as an attorney,
you really have to have a
command of the English language.
You need to know how to write well,
and write clearly so
people will understand
what you're saying.
Talk a little about that,
and where did you get this
sense of the importance of words
and of writing, at law school?
- I think as an undergraduate.
I think as I was going through
San Diego State University,
I became aware of that,
and became very fascinated with the idea
of developing ideas and
being able to carry,
to develop them crisply
and yet, carry meaning,
and I became impressed with the idea
that it is not my goal to
write to be understood.
It's to write so that I'll
never be misunderstood,
and that takes a lot of writing,
and I became very aware,
there are not good writers.
There are good editors,
and one has to be able to
constantly relook at their work
to make it more effective
and that takes time.
That takes time, but with
skills that you pick up,
it isn't insurmountable,
but it is time consuming.
- After you graduated from law school,
you practiced law in San Diego,
and talk a little about that.
In other words, what was that
learning experience like?
What kind of cases did
you handle and so on,
and how long did you do it?
- It was an exciting part of my life.
I was very fortunate.
The major firm in San Diego selected me,
I think a lot because I went to Berkeley,
and they've had good experience
with Berkeley graduates,
but those firms were
very small in those days,
and I wanted to be a trial lawyer,
and they gave me that opportunity,
so I was primarily a civil
trial lawyer for 15 years
before I went on the bench,
and I didn't leave the practice of law
because I didn't like it.
There's a lot of things I miss
about the practice of law,
but I enjoyed it, it brought
out the better things in me.
It required me to do far more
than I thought I was capable of,
and that was a very
good experience for me.
Going into trial, representing people,
it's a fascinating thing that you do.
You're doing something they
can't do for themselves,
and you wanna do it well,
and it was, I enjoyed that
part of the law very much.
- And were you involved on
the side in politics at all?
Or did you just practice the law?
- I just practiced law.
There were a few things helping out,
doing a few things, committee,
but between raising a family,
which was my first priority,
and my religious involvement
and practicing law,
there wasn't much time left,
and I never played golf or went fishing.
It was 24 hours a day,
but that was good for me.
That was good for me, too.
It learned, it taught me a discipline,
that I got more out of life,
but I learned most of that at Berkeley,
where I never went to
the drinking fountain
and sat and talked to people.
I went down and got into the books again.
Discipline was something
I learned in law school.
- Mm-hmm.
And hard work, I guess?
- Indeed, indeed.
- And is there any one experience
when you were a practicing attorney
that something clicked in your mind,
that it's kind of enhanced
your ability as a judge,
some recollection, or was
it just the whole body
of the experience?
- I think it was the whole experience.
I had, in the back of my mind, someday,
I might wanna go on the bench,
but I had turned it down several times
to go on the state bench.
The federal bench is, it's
a different type of work,
much more consistent
with what I wanted to do.
I actually went on a little earlier
than I would've preferred.
I was 41 when I went
on the district court.
- And that would be what year?
- 1970.
- Okay.
- And I was just in a partnership
where I was beginning to make some money,
after struggling along,
and it was a time that was not
the most convenient for me,
but a partner from another
law firm came to me and said,
this opportunity's here; we'd
like to have you take it,
and we gave it serious
consideration, decided to do it.
- And you were appointed
to the district court
by President Nixon and where
we you based, in San Diego?
- I was.
I was in the Southern
District of California,
and the courthouse there
is in downtown San Diego.
Then two years later,
one of my colleagues
on the court of appeals
was going senior, and he
wanted me to take his place
and I got another telephone call,
whether I'd be willing to
go on the court of appeals,
so I did, in 1972.
- And that, you were also
appointed by President Nixon,
to that, yeah.
And how do these, conceptually,
these courts differ?
In other words, as a district judge,
you are lower in the
hierarchy of the court system,
the federal court system.
What is the breadth of the kind of cases
that come before you,
and are they closer to real human beings
in their conflicts and
so on in that sense?
- Yes, they certainly are.
Anything that's a federal crime
or a federal civil matter,
anything of federal
jurisdiction came before us,
and of course, we're next to the border,
so we had a lot of crime,
and I had never even tried
a criminal case before then,
so that was a new area.
There wasn't much of a change
of going from being a lawyer
to being a trial judge.
I pretty well, I developed
that fairly easy,
and the criminal law's not difficult.
The civil law is more difficult,
and I had been working with civil law.
So I didn't find it a big transition.
It was nice, and I enjoyed doing that,
but the thing that struck me
about going to the court of appeals
was I could change my primary skill.
My primary skill was oral
when I was a trial lawyer,
as a trial judge.
Now at the court of appeals,
it would be written skills,
and I just thought that'd
be an interesting challenge
to see the broader picture of establishing
the fabric of the law would
be something I would enjoy,
and it turned out, I did.
- And talk a little about the
dynamics on an appeal court.
Now, let me ask this first.
Tell us, you are on the 9th circuit.
Where is the 9th circuit?
Where do the cases come
from that you deal with?
- The 9th circuit is
the nine western states,
and the islands of the Pacific.
It's the largest circuit
in the United States,
has about 55, 60 million
people within the circuit.
The cases come from the
district court, the trial court,
and also from the
agencies, federal agencies.
They also have an access to our court.
So that's where our jurisdiction is.
It's a very dynamic area.
We have more diversity
than any other circuit.
Unfortunately, we have more cases, too,
and that creates some problems,
but it's very meaningful,
the types of cases,
the types of issues.
I've never been bored.
- Mm-hmm, and you mentioned the diversity
within the courts covered by,
and we're gonna talk
about this a little later,
about the work you've done
in trying to bring diversity
to the court system, but talk a little
about how your sensitivity to
issues of diversity emerged.
Was it through the nature
of the cases that you were getting,
was it the political dynamic
in the country and so on?
- The political dynamic
never entered at all.
I was never asked once how I'd
vote on a particular issue.
In those early days, they
had some way of finding you,
but it was largely the
people who had achieved
within the profession and were willing
to take the necessary sacrifice in salary
in order to go on the bench.
So that wasn't the issue.
What really took place
was all of a sudden,
instead of finding the law to apply it,
I was going to apply the law,
and I found that there were a lot of areas
where it wasn't clear,
and what you were trying to do was decide
what that law should be.
Now some feel that the court
should be a social instrument for change.
I never believed that.
I believe too much in democracy.
The people don't always get it right,
but there's a dynamic
to letting people make those decisions.
So I have been in the group of judges,
which they call judicial restraint judges.
That's neither conservative nor liberal.
It's just how you approach your task,
and as I worked longer and longer within,
being an appellate judge,
this became more and
more significant to me
on how I approach
problems that come to us,
and all my brothers and
sisters on the court
don't feel the same way I do.
Some of them feel the
other way, and that's okay.
I just don't think it's the way
that we were supposed to be, as judges.
So there's still a great disagreement
across the United States among judges,
and among law professors and other,
what is the real role of a judge?
Is a judge someone, when
they don't get it right,
through the democratic process, we fix it?
Or do we require the democratic
process to move forward
and get the job done,
and we just make the
application of the law itself?
It's a very interesting question.
- And I wanna explore
this, but as part of a,
to give a fuller sense
of what a judge does.
As I listen to you, you
reminder of the philosophers
who I've had on this program,
in the sense a philosopher will tell me,
well, what we try to do is
bring order to the chaos
of a particular phenomena,
and it sounds to me,
is it fair to say that
you're saying, in a way,
that there are areas
where the law is not clear
about what should be done,
but this, in your view,
is not about making political decisions,
but rather, coming up with
rules that will sort out
a particular area and
offer greater definition
of where one can go
and where one can't go?
That's maybe superficial, but is that,
can we help our audience understand
what it is you're sorting
out as you decide a case
at the appellate level?
- Well, as an example, the
Congress isn't always as careful
as they oughta be with their legislation.
I understand that.
They have to go through compromises,
and they have much work to do,
but it leaves certain
gaps as to what is meant,
and then they come to court,
because there's a dispute,
and we have to make a decision
what is the law going to be,
what is the rule going to be,
and then it depends on how
you go about doing that?
Do you look at some view that you have
of the way society should
be, or do you look,
and try and find out what it
is the legislature had in mind?
And then, whether you agree
with what the legislature did or not,
that's not the issue.
The issue is does that rule,
is it consistent with
what they were trying,
the elected representatives,
were trying to do?
And to that extent, you're
developing less chaos,
because you're establishing rules.
They may not be rules that you like,
they may not be rules that Congress likes,
but they can always amend their statutes,
so that's not a a problem.
If you get it wrong, they
have the great erasure,
and they can take care of it.
But that's, I think there's a lot to that,
to the extent we're able to define
what they have made unclear,
there's less chaos in the world.
- Now, you know, of course,
the Berkeley tradition,
which you know is activism
and social change and so on,
but you're suggesting that
you fall in the category
of judges who wanna
defer to the legislature,
and what are the rules
about drawing that line?
I mean, are there criteria in your mind
that help you navigate this area
where you're trying to clarify
the rules on the one hand,
but I think what you're saying
is you don't wanna make
the rules of the law,
you wanna defer to the legislature.
- Yes.
I think there's times when you can't tell
whether a person believes
in judicial restraint
or judicial activism, but certainly,
the approach is different
and the idea behind
what I like to call judicial restraint
is that it gives the greatest opportunity
for democracy to work.
Now it's slower, I understand that,
and people get concerned.
They wanna do an end run
around the democratic process
to get to the courts,
but the Constitution wasn't
made to solve all problems.
It's very small, and the
idea behind the Constitution
was restrict the national government,
and those rules were ones that would allow
this great democratic force to start,
not only through the states,
but the national government, as well.
So I don't see this as,
judicial restraint as one
in which your foot is on the brake pedal.
On the contrary, I think what it does
is excite the democratic process,
to get people to get out and get involved.
Now we haven't done very
well in that, as a country.
I mean, look at how many
people come out to vote.
We say we're a democracy,
but we haven't been able
to catch the view that it really matters
that one vote, and I think
it's best for the United States
to move in that direction.
I just believe, well, it's
like Winston Churchill said,
that democracy is
absolutely the worst type
of government there is,
except for all others have been tried.
It's not perfect, but I think
it's best for the people.
So my philosophy, my judicial
philosophy is consistent
with that approach.
- Now over the years that
you have been a lawyer,
a judge, at the district level,
and then at the circuit
court level, the judiciary,
in a way, has become a kind of a football,
a political football,
and there have been a lot of complaints
about politicization,
some of them more than
complaints and so on.
Talk about this era that you've
lived through as a judge,
and what are the factors
that helped the system
write itself, restore the balance?
Is it the fact that parties are in power
at different times,
and it's about the
election of our leaders,
who then write the balance
on particular issues?
- There's been a substantial change
in the way federal
judges are selected now.
When I went on the bench in the 70s,
of course, the President
was gonna pick people
from his own party, most of the time.
Richard Nixon didn't.
He picked Democrats as
well as Republicans,
but most of them would
pick from their own party.
The question is, do you want
somebody who is going to be,
have the views of society that you have,
or are you looking for a good lawyer?
Now in the early days, they
looked for the good lawyer.
What was most important
was the ABA going out,
and making sure you're a
good lawyer, and of course,
the FBI to make sure you
weren't a crook someplace,
but that, well, there was no
question asked of me of that.
I didn't fill out any forms,
and when I went back to the Congress,
no one asked me how I
would vote on abortion,
or how I'd vote on this or that.
That was not part of the process.
Now over a period of time, that changed,
where presidents felt that
they wanted to get people
that had their view of society,
and so they would be these litmus tests,
and things like that,
and so it became very politicized
because they wanted that kind of a judge,
and then those judges
would come out and say,
I've got a mission to change,
and it skewed the whole
process, in my view.
Now that's true of Republicans,
it's true of Democrats.
It turned into a process in
which they not only politicized
but they looked at the
jury, at the judiciary,
as a way of achieving a
certain goal politically,
sociologically, as they saw it,
and I think that's been very unfortunate.
I think that's it's damaged our judiciary,
and I think it's caused the
judiciary to look at itself
in a different way, and I think
a way that is not consistent
with what the founders had in mind,
nor what's best for America.
- So your ideal, it sounds like,
and I think you're arguing
that this was really the tradition
until the more recent times
was a kind of insulation
of the judiciary from a political process,
which then empowers it to do
this sorting out of the rules
based on the law that's been created
by the democratic process.
- Yeah, yes.
- Interesting.
So how, then do you sort of
navigate the system back?
Let's assume that we want,
the audience wanted to buy
into what you're saying,
the way the judiciary was in the past.
How does one best achieve that
return to the kind of vision
that you had, and that really
was the way the courts worked
in earlier period?
- Well, I think it's gonna
take an educational process.
I just don't, I mean, if you
talk to the average person,
what they want the court to do
is make a decision they like,
not one that's consistent
with some other goals,
and to get the view of what a judiciary,
what will be the best type
of judiciary for the future,
it's gonna require an educational process.
Now whether that's gonna
take place in high school
and college or whether it's
gonna place through the media,
I have no way of knowing,
but it will take a change of view.
Politicians react to majorities.
If the political feels this isn't the way
they want judges selected,
there's less likelihood they're
gonna go that direction,
and that's right.
That's the way it should be,
so until the people become interested
in making those kinds of modifications,
I don't see much happening.
Now and then, there'll
be a convert to my view.
I remember when I made my
first determination on this,
that I was gonna come
out and talk about it,
I gave a lecture at George
Washington University
called The Jurisprudence
of Judicial Restraint:
A Return to the Moorings,
and that was how I felt about it.
We were returning to something
that we should get to,
and I would like to see
more people involved.
- Now as part of this education process,
it would seem that the
people, the activists,
the community that wants change now,
and doesn't wanna wait,
and I think this is true,
one could say, of both
the right and the left.
- Oh, there's no question.
- So what is the handle for
making those constituencies
understand the costs of
what they're proposing?
Because they may win today,
I think you're saying,
if the courts get politicized,
but then the pendulum
will swing the other way,
and then everybody says, well,
we can't trust the judges,
because they've been politicized.
- Yeah.
I think it's just a question
of seeing what they're asking for.
For example, they're saying, I
believe in judicial activism,
but only if it's activists
in my point of view,
and for example, suppose all nine members
of the Supreme Court,
this will never happen,
suppose all nine members
of the Supreme Court
belonged to the Ku Klux Klan,
would you want that
court to be activistic?
Well, the answer is no,
you wouldn't want them.
Well, that means that it's a
result oriented philosophy.
Judicial activism is result oriented,
and there are conservative
judicial activists,
and there are liberal judicial activists.
So if people can understand that,
that they may want activists,
but they want them if
they'll go the direction
and maybe they won't have them,
then they may think about
is there a better way?
In the grand scheme of things,
what's the best way for us
to have governance in our country?
And maybe when we ask those questions,
we'll come out with a different answer.
- You were the chief judge
for a number of years, right?
- Five years.
- Five years, from what year to what year?
- '91 to '96.
- And in that capacity,
you were also an
administrator of the court,
the chief administrator.
What is involved in those tasks?
- The administration is
what makes the machine work,
and most judges don't care
much for administration.
They like to be on the bench.
In the early '70s,
I got interested in
judicial administration.
I started studying it, writing it,
and even taught courses in
judicial administration,
so by the time I became chief
judge of the largest circuit,
I had a tremendously interesting challenge
and we made a lot of
progress, in my judgment.
You continue to be a judge,
you continue to sit on cases,
but you get to deal with
how can you make the process better?
That is, how can you get
the cases through quicker?
How can you provide the necessary things
to make us more efficient, more effective?
It's a little like going into a business.
You sort of look at what your stock is
and how you can best get it out.
Now we get chief judges
by staying the longer,
so it's a little, sometimes
like getting a good teacher
and making him a principal, and they fail.
There's no test you take
to be a chief judge.
Some like it better than others.
But it is an exciting time,
and we did some interesting
things that I really enjoyed.
- And what does it take
to reform the courts
in the capacity that you have?
Can you give an example of
something that you want done
and you were able to do it?
Is it just by virtue of
the power of your role,
or is it by virtue of
your ability to persuade
your colleagues or the
courts under you to follow?
- I wish it were by the power.
It would've been much easier.
When you're a chief judge, it's
a little like herding cats.
Keeping them together in
one group is very difficult,
and you have to have a critical
mass of the court in favor,
so it is talking to people,
getting people convinced,
and that means it's slower.
There's none of them you can fire.
You're not running General Motors,
so you deal with what you've got,
and you try and move towards the process.
Now it wasn't very often
than I had 100% unanimity
of these views, because it required judges
to change what they're doing,
and judges are very conservative,
most conservative people,
maybe lawyers, too.
Once they do something,
they wanna continue
the way they're doing it,
and they keep saying, if it
ain't broke, don't fix it,
and I would say, is there a better way?
And the two philosophies
have a tendency to collide,
but I think as we
continued to work together
on these issues, we did
some remarkable things
during those five years.
I'm very pleased with what
my colleagues on the court
allowed us to do.
- Now one of the issues in
your role as a court leader,
both on the 9th circuit
and in the judicial system,
and your role as an administrator,
you've actually been
involved in bringing issues
to the table, I think as
part of the organization,
and so you've been very active
in bringing greater diversity
to the courts system, I
assume in terms of judges
and personnel, and the way the courts act,
and then talk a little about that,
and what was the obstacle there,
the sense that the country wasn't prepared
for the challenge of diversity,
I'm not talking about
places like the Bay Area
or California and so on.
- No, we had that same process.
I think the one thing
that we had to make clear,
that we hire people and they're retained
for their abilities, not
for their own social views
or their own particular ways of living,
so long as they create
an example on the court
that gives what the
judiciary example should be,
and we did, I think a
very good job with that.
We have a very large clerk's office,
and if you walked in there
and talked to people,
you would see a very diverse group.
The more difficult process
was trying to figure out
what do we owe to the people as far
as the courts are concerned,
the judges are concerned,
the system itself?
And just before I came on,
we had started this effort
to find out whether or not
there's gender fairness
and that was just coming to an end,
and we were very successful in that,
and so my role was taking
the second step of race,
religion and ethnicity,
and we had a taskforce
that we put together, and I
had to talk to a lot of judges
to make sure that I wasn't
gonna get a lot of opposition,
and let them know why
I'm doing what I'm doing,
and we got David Levi, who
is now Dean of the Law School
at Duke, he was a judge, his
father was Attorney General,
very bright guy, and he agreed
to chair that taskforce,
and it was very successful.
But those are the kinds of issues,
to see if there are headwinds
within the court system.
We can't solve everything in the world,
but we can make sure our court system
is as pure as it can be, and
that was a good experience.
I enjoyed that.
- And were there any
particular obstacles to this?
In other words, I guess, in a way,
what we're saying is that when
the country faces a challenge
that the court system is
a microcosm within that,
when we're talking about reforming itself,
and with the right
leadership, it can adapt.
- Yes, and we just have to make sure,
and very often, we're
doing things inadvertently.
For example, a judge says, Mr. Smith,
what's your position on this?
Mary, what's your position?
Now, he doesn't mean to
push the gender button,
but it's just people got
used to doing those things,
and what we had to do was
call it to their attention
so they just give thought to it,
and judges are fine people, but they, too,
have to be reminded that
they are setting an example
for the judiciary, and if inadvertently,
they do something, it reflects
on all of the judiciary.
- Now I know one of
your great achievements
in public service has been the work
with court systems abroad,
and I think that you were
involved in this process,
an active leader with
Chief Justice Burger,
for establishing the
American Inns of Court.
Explain what that was, and what
you were trying to achieve.
- Chief Justice Burger believed in change,
and he was leading a team in
an Anglo-American exchange.
He invited me to the team.
Lord Diplock had the English side,
and we were looking at procedure.
The result of that was that we visited
the English Inns of Court.
Chief Justice Burger and
I were sitting in the bus,
waiting for the rest of the
group to come one morning,
and I pointed out to him that
I thought that the English
had a very good idea of
how they trained lawyers,
and I thought we could
maybe adapt that principle
to what we have in the United States,
so Chief Justice Burger
said he liked my idea,
he said, why don't you go ahead and see
what you can find out about it,
so I started talking with a lot of people,
spent a lot of time, developed a process,
and then developed the first pilot program
for the American Inns of Court,
and now there are 26,000
people in the United States,
judges and lawyers who are
involved in this process
of trying to make lawyers
learn the importance
of how they function in court:
civility, professionalism, preparation.
It used to be that you
learned from the person
who you carried the bag
for, in the big firm.
They don't have that experience anymore.
- Are you talking about
the lawyers abroad?
- No, here.
- Here, yeah.
- Yeah.
And so this was to take the place of that,
and it's been very well-received.
We now have our first Inn overseas.
I work with a conference
of Chief Justice of Asia
in the Pacific, 34 chief justices
representing two thirds of
the population of the world.
We are going to have a presentation
on Inn of Court process
for them this coming November,
when we meet in Ho Chi Minh City,
and we hope, now that this example
that we've been able to show as successful
in the United States can be exported.
- Mm-hmm.
- Lawyers need it everywhere.
- And what is it about the process,
first at home, is it having courses
or people coming, lawyers coming,
or judges coming as observers
to leaders in the field?
- It's actually like an inn.
There will be so many senior people
made up of lawyers and judges,
so many in medium and
some that are very new.
They meet together and
discuss these processes.
They have pupillages,
they have small groups and large groups
and then, the younger people
and the medium people,
they phase out, and they
bring more people in.
So it's not trying to lecture hundreds.
It's just changing a few
people so that good examples
go into court, and that's
the theme behind it,
and that's what's working pretty well.
- What is your idea
about how this could help
spread the rule of law abroad?
Because listening to you,
I think you have a respect
for the process of democracy,
and it would seem that
the process of democracy
in different parts of the world
are gonna reflect national culture,
political history, and so on,
and so the question becomes,
are there particular problems
with teaching the American example,
with regard to law in
different national settings?
Obviously, that's a better way to go
than to try to do this through
military force, in my view.
Talk a little about what the
challenges might be there.
- I've now worked directly
in over 60 countries
throughout the world, on every continent,
where I've spent actual
time with the judiciaries,
and through international meetings,
I've probably interacted
with over a hundred.
I don't try to sell the American model.
The American model is
wonderful for America,
but it very often is not relevant
to those individual countries.
I may see something in
Indonesia that I think
is far more important, or
I was in, two weeks ago,
I was in Vietnam, and they were
trying to develop a program
and I remembered a program
I worked on in Nigeria
that had a better model,
and so that's the model
that I recommended.
So the idea is to try and
work with these court systems,
to make them more effective,
but based upon their
religious, their culture
and their local legal culture,
and what fits best with
them, and very often,
what we have won't, then,
developing their judiciary,
so it's more effective,
that they buy into it,
it's their idea, they
develop their judiciary,
they develop their lawyers.
Then, that is a piece of
getting towards democracy.
Obviously, I don't have any feeling
that I'm changing the world,
but there is a small area
that I can be of help,
and that is developing,
helping them to develop
their legal system so
it can take the place
that a judiciary should
in a democratic process.
- I detect, in all that you've said
a philosophy of modesty and humility
tied to intellectual rigor,
if I can say, that reflects the way
you see the Inn of Courts abroad,
but also in the way you see the judiciary
in our political system.
Is that fair?
I mean, you seem to recognize the limits
of what courts do, and if that's true,
do you feel, sometimes,
that we overemphasize,
that we think, we expect too much
of both lawyers and courts?
- Mm-hmm, I do, and I
think one of the things
that I've always talked
about is the importance
of judicial humility, that is,
the humility to recognize
what our role is,
and we shouldn't usurp the
role of the political branches,
and I think that that's true,
that if we focus on what we
were supposed to be doing,
that requires the political branches
to focus on what they ought to be doing,
and I think that's true, not only here,
but it's true overseas.
The best thing that we can do
overseas in these countries,
from my view of what
little I can contribute,
is to make their
judiciaries more effective,
so that they are protecting rights,
they're enforcing the Constitution.
I always said the best
thing we can do for dictator
is to give them a good
independent judiciary.
It'll take time.
I mean, all of these
countries are in transition,
and in judicial administration,
there are no bandaids.
It takes years.
Former Chief Justice
Vanderbilt of New Jersey said,
judicial administration is
not for the short winded,
and that's true.
We're distance runners, and
we talk in terms of decades,
and not years or months.
But there are things we can do
and we should start doing more of them,
to assist overseas the
judiciaries and the lawyers,
to make them more effective.
It's nice we're sending
them guns and planes,
and I think maybe that's important,
but for longterm benefits,
we shouldn't overlook the possibility
of helping them develop structures,
which will protect human
rights within the country.
- As we think about the
role of lawyers and judges
in the future, it would
seem that maybe we have
too many lawyers in the legislature,
and not enough theologians
and other educators
and others who can bring different skills,
so I'm curious about what you
see is the overuse of lawyers.
I'm not asking you to
criticize the legislature,
but clearly, lawyers
have something to add,
but is it sometimes the
case that too many lawyers
is not a good thing as we're looking
at different institutions
besides the courts?
- I don't know.
I think that we get there for a reason.
What is there about lawyers
that become politicians?
And lawyers, of course, are focusing
upon a very important process
in the judicial system,
and they do it on a daily basis,
where a doctor is operating on a table,
a professor is teaching in a school,
but lawyers are right in
the middle of this mix,
and I think that it's just the very nature
of the type of person
who's drawn to the law
and their experience
being constantly immersed
in this process that sort of makes people
gravitate towards that,
so I'm not sure that we
have too many lawyers.
Maybe it's just that whatever they are,
we need more statesmen.
- Well said.
One other area that I
wanted to ask you about.
We're in kind of a
foreign policy crisis now.
We're also in an economic crisis,
and so there's gonna be
a lot of looking back,
with regard to the economic collapse,
a lot of cases coming before judges,
and then, in the war on terrorism,
clearly, there's a lot of rule setting.
Now I'm curious as to what
you see the role of the courts
in dealing these two areas,
where we're really gonna have to have
a lot of new rulemaking.
We're gonna also have the possibility
of investigations about what went wrong,
what should we do about it, and so on.
But I'm curious is,
are there any red flags
that you would like to hold up
about what the courts can do
and what they can't do,
and the contribution
that judges and lawyers can make,
even if we have a commission, say,
and it's not thrown at the courts.
On the other hand, all this may come
before the different courts
to solve different problems
related to these two
very important issues,
where we're really unsure
about the way to proceed.
- Mm-hmm.
I think there are issues that
are coming along the pike
that are gonna be that way.
The whole idea of genetics
is going to change markedly
how courts function, what kinds of issues
they're gonna have to deal with.
I was involved in a
three year study on that.
It was enough to frighten me.
But I think that we have
to be flexible enough
to meet those that come along,
that'll require judges to become educated
in certain fashions
and to the extent that we
are called upon to do it,
we have to prepare.
On the other hand, we
can't use the judiciary
as a universal fix it.
In the recent coup that
took place in Thailand,
the story is told of the king
calling the judiciary over
in a private meeting, and
saying democracy needs fixing;
you fix it.
Well, we're not qualified,
either by our individuality
or by our role to fix democracy.
Over the longterm we can help
it by not taking it over,
but the idea to fix a democratic problem
that they had there, we just couldn't do,
and I think we have to be careful trying
to give those things to the court.
Very often, for example,
in many countries,
they get judges to behead commissions.
Why?
Because they think the
people with the black robe on
will be thought better of by the people.
We did that once with President
Kennedy's assassination,
and the chief justice thought
it was a great mistake,
and he was sorry he ever decided
that he would go along with it,
because it changes the role of the judge,
which you have to be very
careful to not do that,
and England does it all the time,
but it's not our philosophy.
So I think we're gonna have to be careful
what role the court should play
in these very important areas.
Critically, we have to play the role
of defending the Constitution,
to the extent any of these things,
the war on terrorism, or whatever,
is inconsistent with the Constitution,
those cases have to come to court,
and we have to be strong
enough to make those decisions.
No matter what the future is,
no matter how difficult it is,
the Constitution is so fundamental
that we have to find a way
of solving our problems
without violating it.
So the Constitution, I
think, puts us in a position
of having to be very vigilant.
On the other hand, there are many things
that could occur outside the Constitution,
and the political process is
gonna have to sort that out.
- One final question.
If students were watching this program,
and they look at your career,
and they say, yeah, I
would like to do that,
how should they prepare for law in a world
that's gonna be changing a lot,
and the change we're experiencing?
- Yeah.
I don't have any real answer to that.
I think it's more a matter of interest.
If a person really wants to come into law,
there's so many different areas
of law they can deal with now,
not only domestically,
but internationally,
and so a very broad educational process
that gives a person a very substantial,
wide ranging experience,
will be of great help to them,
because judges more and more now
have to have peripheral vision.
We used to just focus this way,
but we've gotta see what that means.
If we're gonna make that decision
having to do with the anti-trust law,
but what does that mean outside here?
And we have to be able
to see that process,
what that means, and I think to the extent
that we get better strengthening
of educational process,
more in the liberal arts,
that we seem to think
is not necessary now.
If it is, two and two doesn't equal four,
we're not interested.
I see it different.
I think we have to have that wider vision
to bring to the task what's
gonna be necessary in the future
'cause truly, it is gonna be different.
- Judge Wallace, I wanna
thank you very much
for coming back to the Berkeley campus.
Congratulations on your award,
and thank you for being on our program.
- My pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(upbeat music)